this is an anniversary of a very special
day
in tony larussa's life and career he
made his managerial debut on august 3rd
1979 managing the sox club dylan sees up
for his 22nd start looking for his
eighth win as zra a touch over four a
lot of strikeouts this year as the stuff
keeps getting better and better
and he struck him out foul tip on a
heater
[Applause]
that is inside for a walk so once again
this year carlos santana is down in the
count but gets on base with the walk
[Applause]
and he got him foul tip
two k's in the first for dylan cease
and we'll see if chris bubich can pick
up where he left off on wednesday
against the white sox
and he takes a walk
change up is hit to dozier on the left
side
and that'll do it
dozier strikes out number three early on
for cease
3-2 got him swinging wow three straight
strikeouts for cease
[Applause]
rounded to dozier bare hands throws in
time look at the top spin it's still
rolling pretty hard but a nice little
hop up for him that's a great play there
no doubt the biggest area where you feel
really good about andrew vaughn is of
late he's having more success against
righties
before
that baby's gonna go
sox lead early one to nothing
and that's why you're gonna love andrew
vaughn he can wait back
and not get out on the front foot keep
his hands back and still make good
contact and ride it out for his 12 home
run
[Applause]
whack to center field and shallow and
it's going to drop
in between hernandez and engel and
that's the royals first hit
swinging in the miss there will be no
blooper in this sit-back
and he went around
and he's going to make it
there goes merrifield and a chop to
first fair ball throw to the plate
no hesitation by jose
and nobody out in the inning you want to
come away with at least one run this
inning and make the lead-off walk really
come back to haunt bobich
that is to right
it's deep and it's gone
two-run homer tim anderson it's three
nothing sometimes doing the right thing
turns into gold he was going that way he
got it up in the wind and he's hit
double figures in home runs that's his
tenth
[Applause]
and attendees on with the lead off walk
and cease did not want to do that
ben attendee runs
a strikeout and
ben and tindy got his left arm in there
and now he's grabbing his left shoulder
he's able to beat the one hopper there
but just just wrenched his shoulder
only helping him off the field but you
can tell he is
helping keep that
shoulder
right where it is
high in the air to left back on it
vaughn just a quick
glance back and he's got enough room to
make the catch
here's the 91st pitch from dylan it's a
grounder to tim anderson couple of hops
out with it quickly
good throw over to first gets him
brubush strikes out his fourth
struck out three in a row and four or
five
dozier will field and
he's not going to get him anderson with
a base hit on the infield
fastball got him looking so it's
three strikeouts three more strikeouts
for buuvich in the fifth
strike three
strikeout number 10 for cease
and he's got 11. he just struck out the
side
michael kopeck comes on
25th time 3-1 e.r.a of two and a half
breaking ball stayed up and dozier hits
it into deep left center field and engel
had a chance to catch it but he
overextended
and dozier is going to end up
at third base with a lead off triple
and now it's o'hern
and now o'hearn hits it deep enough
into left center field engel's going to
get behind it but dozier tags and comes
down from third and the royals are on
the board on a ryan o'hearn sacrifice
fly
here's kyle zimmer and a chevy call to
the bullpen with a 4.17 era but so far
the second half hasn't been very kind to
kyle zimmer
and he walked him to start the inning
fawn draws a free pass so two on nobody
out
and he has walked the bases loaded
richard lovelady comes out for the tenth
time
a little flinch by
the empire wendelstep
savannah will get an rbi monkatta will
score four consecutive walks to start
the inning it's four to one
tim with a chance to add to this lead
into center it's gonna get down
everybody should advance one
it's an rbi hit for tim
his third of the night
it's five to one
one out now base is loaded for jose
abreu 5-1 socks
[Applause]
it's going to get in there
zabala will score
anderson right behind him
great job by tim he just kept on running
good read on it 7-1
tupara comes in the ball game on for the
46th time
you see the numbers
get a really good run over on the north
side he's come here couple of outings
that were
not what he would like but as len says
turns it around with one good outing
here
on the ground toward first
and the sox take the opener
to pera one two three ninth inning
that's the type of outing he needed